quand j'entends valérie et ludivine oui
nous donner ce que doit être le sommaire
d'envoyé spécial c'est la télévision et
ça c'est un reporter les délices que
l'événement on vient fait je comprends
même pas regardé pour dire une bêtise
imagine août les théâtres et taxis cela
devrait se taire j'ai mis en cause par
un ils assument de il répond non c'est
non alors s'il a répondu au journal la
suite du reportage
ensuite il vient répondre en disant je
prends tout maxime âme et un couple
maximum mea culpa ce n'est moi et que
moi et donc il
il a d'abord refusé cette série que je
te guérit au cas où il y aurait une
vidéo qui est kader aoun qui est un oui
compris que travailler avec eux avec mme
giguère
c'est lui qui était qui quittent
président en cause et c'est vrai que on
a les images il n'a pas souhaité
répondre oui oui oui mais pas thomert
renom absolument sûr je vais le dire
nous allons à sa rencontre
persuadé qu'après une poignée de main
entre le rideau le nawab de l'humour
nous éclairera est-ce que vous avez où
ils ont pillé des humoristes américains
cette fois
est ce que oui ou non vous êtes servis
chez des auteurs américains un homme à
craon kader aoun au lendemain de notre
rencontre il nous adresse ce sms et
semblent désigner un coupable
je n'ai rien à me reprocher dans cette
histoire si vous voulez avoir des
informations de première main
je vous invite à contacter monsieur
thomert 6 les voilà à lui les terribles
lui aurait tué ou un peu on a de très
bons artistes en france faut arrêter les
dénigrer faut arrêter de les clashs et
tomer sisley et talentueux même s'il
copie même si c'est inspiré d'un sketch
américain pour si la pâte alan hippe son
sketch ne sera pas bon il sera mauvais
temps avec du talent peu pour elle galli
je comprends on va voir ce qu'ont
répondu les américains vous allez voir
que eux
et d'ailleurs c'est normal c'est leur
gagne pain
on peut pas le peuple sait que
effectivement même si on reconnaît même
si on dit oui effectivement je me suis
inspiré pour les auteurs et croyez moi
et le taux qui sont pas des stars qui ne
vivent que de droits d'auteur c'est un
drame de céréales honnêtement
alors je fonce de tomates au maire a dit
celui qui veut frapper à ma porte et qui
veut au prorata du skate
les seconds que je lui paye mais vite il
est repassé le maire a dit voilà je les
fais à hauteur de tentes
il a été radical est attendu c'est le
qe2 est juste une seconde on va regarder
ce que ce qu'ont répondu les ricains
valoir que les ricains
comme dirait sadoul s'il n'était pas là
bas on a besoin de skate sur la d ici en
amérique et en baskets violet un sketch
et ça peut anéantir votre carrière cela
colle au cul ses excuses st onge années
au sein des aspects pas juste en
appelait ça des comics ces humoristes
français
ce sont des politiques mais il s'énerve
c'est normal non c'est compréhensible
mais après mais pas dire est ce qu'on en
voit ce qu'on leur à contextualiser est
ce qu'on la douleur 30% sur 100 % est ce
qu'on leur a dit un jeune alors que zain
qui l'avait belge et revoilà va quand
même temps qu'ils avaient soit carrément
pompe est complètement à 100% soit juste
30% soit juste une phrase sur 20 ans de
carrière
donc voilà il faut nuancer salue le
comportement de tomer sisley qui a été à
l'avant parce que dans sa réponse
absolument et ses classes il était
honnête là encore là et l'a connu le
reportage est approximatif c'est ça
qu'on peut lui reprocher passe pas et
prennent le cas de roland magdane qui
flingue
roland magdane ilham et or oui il a
travaillé aux états unis qu'il ait
exprimé par les américains pour des
stand-up qu'il a fait là bas donc
forcément il n'a pas tout piqué et c'est
en ça que le reportage peut-être on doit
écrire des mails verra débarquer ce qui
est assez intéressant vous allez voir
c'est qu'il y en a un qui a dit une
chose apparemment vrai enfin c'est que
les semoun a dit voilà on le son le
cédant métiers ont nettement qu on sait
qui c'est on sait ce qu'ils ont fait et
on sait ce qu'ils ont été prendre c'est
une confession à assez fortes regardez
bon je me suis pas penché sur le sur ces
histoires là mais en toute sincérité
là je préfère vous parlez comme un homme
politique c'est à dire je les hais ce
qu'il est en fait non franchement donc
tous les possibles si j'acceptais je
crois sans dans le métier tout le monde
le sait tout le monde sait que certains
artistes vont sur internet où vont aux
états unis et comme je disais tout à
l'heure pense que oui c'est un secret de
polichinelle bien sûr dans mon métier on
sait exactement qui est copieurs qui
plaît oui oui ça c'est dit c'est fait
évader marco vous pu quérir beau vous
reprenez nous on fait des reprises voilà
et les hommages des sauvages